So Thank you, everyone.
My name is David Smith and
I'm a developer advocate
at Microsoft.
And if you've ever given a
tutorial using R or just
tried to share R
code with other people
and gotten these
kind of responses,
then this talk is for you.
Now you might get
these kind of reactions
because somebody didn't
read the setup instructions
or installed the
wrong version of R.
And so your code
doesn't work or they're
using a different operating
system than you expect,
or just using an old
laptop that can't
cope with the data and the
code that you provided.
But you can resolve
all of these issues
by running in something
called GitHub CodeSpaces.
So let's see how this works.
I've got here a repository,
which you can find on GitHub.
It has everything you
need to recreate what
I'm showing you right here.
But one of the
things that it does
include is a .devcontainer
folder, and that
is the magic that allows you
to click on that code button
directly in GitHub and then run
the code within CodeSpaces.
Now this is running
in real time.
It takes about 10 or 20 seconds.
What GitHub is doing right here
is setting up a CodeSpace,
kind of like a little
virtual machine that
has the version of
R that I specified
installs all the R package
versions that I specified.
It also installs python, my
data, my code, everything
is all right there,
ready for anybody
who clicks on the button to
get exactly in the environment
that I intended for somebody
to run my code within.
So once that CodeSpace launches
in just a couple of seconds,
what we'll see is
a web interface
that looks much like
Visual Studio Code.
And in fact, this is Visual
Studio Code running directly
within the browser.
And I can do all
the usual things
like browsing within my system
that comes from my repository.
This is actually a
tutorial that comes
from a collection provided by
Microsoft, including a Jupyter
notebook, which is
to teach somebody
how to do data
exploration using R.
So there's notebook has popped
up directly within Visual Studio
Code and I can
interact with it as you
would any other notebook.
Like I can run this
cell right here.
And the surprising thing is
that runs without any errors,
without any setup, because
all of those packages
are already preinstalled
within the CodeSpace.
So your participants can then
interact with the notebook,
run the code.
Here's a tidyverse function
which is reading in a data file
and showing in the
first few lines.
It's a very, very
natural experience,
regardless what kind of
laptop that they brought
to the workshop with them.
But what if you wanted to run
your workshop within RStudio
instead of Visual Studio Code?
That's easy too, because we
have RStudio Server installed
within this CodeSpace.
There's need to go to the ports
tab in Visual Studio Code,
and that launches RStudio Server
directly within my browser.
So this is the same as
RStudio on the desktop,
just running on a browser and
I can use that to open files.
And again, I'm going to open
a file from my repository.
They happen to live in
the workspaces folder
when it's running on the server.
Then I browse through
that and this time
let's grab an RMarkdown
document instead.
So we can see how that
works within CodeSpaces.
Now we have R Markdown
documents and we can just
use the usual knit
function within RStudio
to Knit it to HTML and we can
see our output really quickly
because it's running
on a machine with lots
of RAM, lots of CPU.
So these computations
happen nice and fast.
This is all thanks to the menu.
The magic rather
of dev containers,
which is a standardized
way of setting up
a container for
interactive use like this.
You saw that dev container
folder in my repository.
That's where I specify the
R versions, the packages
and everything
else that I needed
to give the same experience
for every user interacts
with my repo. Dev containers, by
the way, are 100% open source
technology.
There is a command
line interface,
so you can integrate
those dev containers
into any application,
not just GitHub,
and you can find
lots of information
about them at containers.dev
But just to give you a little
bit of a flavor of how that
works, if you're
familiar with containers,
you know about
Docker files where
you can specify the
software that gets
installed into that container.
In this particular case, I'm
grabbing a prebuilt container
from the rocker project
and awesome project
providing containers for R.
I chose the version
of R in this case,
it's grabbing the
latest 4.x version.
So I got the very
newest 4.2.1
for that particular
example and I'm
installing a bunch of packages
into that container as well.
There's another file that lets
you configure Visual Studio
Code, set some options if
people are using that editor
and you can also
specify commands
to run at the beginning
of the container,
like starting the
RStudio S erver,
which is how we
got that to work.
So in summary, if you want to do
a tutorial or share some code,
just create a GitHub
repo as you always do.
Put all your scripts, data,
notebooks and instructions
into there, but then set
it up as a dev container
so that all the software
to run your code
is fixed and ready for
anybody to use simply
by clicking on that "Run in
GitHub CodeSpaces" button
directly in GitHub.
Now GitHub CodeSpaces is
only available right now
within GitHub Enterprise
and GitHub Education.
If your participants don't have
access to CodeSpaces today,
they can run out locally
using Visual Studio Code.
And I have another talk which
shows you how that works,
which you can't quite see, but
you can find that link directly
on my GitHub repository that
you see on your
screen right there
with everything you need to
make all this work for you.
Thank you.